listening to a lover is a vital skill in
relationships but there is an associated
and perhaps less well recognised talent
that we may also need to nurture that of
sometimes not quite listening to what a
lover is saying in favor of deftly
imagining what they might really mean
which could be a different thing
altogether though taking someone at face
value is rightly judged to be a supreme
symbol of respect within love it may add
points be more accurate as well as a
great deal kinder to dig beneath the
surface meaning of words in a search for
a partner's real but more bashful
complex or hesitant underlying intention
we need to get better at the business of
emotional translation at navigating the
gap between what people say and what
they mean here are some typical examples
of the divide it can feel profoundly
humiliating to admit to another human
being that they have the power to
unnerve hurt and destroy us to start to
love someone is it wants to be
strengthened in key ways but also to be
weakened and placed at their mercy for
we become if love has gone right heavily
reliant on their good behavior their
kindness and their dependability when
this is not forthcoming we may choose
not to lay bare our weakness to the
lover who has exploited it our
protestations that we're just fine are
an attempt as unconvincing as they are
touching to lay claim to a solidity and
invulnerability that our love has in
fact stripped to solve
it cannot of course be that simple or
that stark for a start we almost never
say such things to people we aren't
certain love us really quite a lot we
need to be very secure and comfortable
around someone before we can dare to
tell them that we want them dead
secondly this kind of rage is evidence
not of simple contempt but rather of
immense hope we don't speak like this to
our colleagues or our friends not just
because we're polite but because we
don't care about them enough
we haven't bothered to expect very much
from them and therefore cannot muster
fury when they disappoint us only when
the bar of expectation has been said
dauntingly hi do we allow ourselves to
give way to boundless fury this kind of
incense talk is one of the order gifts
of love
our authority over our lovers is
frequently rather tenuous there are so
many things we'd like them to do and
want but we cannot sadly direct them
like marionettes often the only recourse
is to demand without asking to imply
without saying we are just being coy
we're up against the limits of what
we're able to control passive aggression
is what happens to dictatorial wishes
when they're tempered by the egalitarian
reality of relationships for the person
on the receiving end it's often hard to
know what's happened they feel
controlled heavy guilty and perhaps a
bit sad the passive-aggressive partner
has been clever enough to leave no
traces of their manipulation on the
surface it sounds like the partner has
some options but within the reality of
the relationship it's evident that they
will simply have to do what they haven't
even directly been asked to do it sounds
controlling and managerial it might be a
follow-on to a request to take out the
bins to count how many bottles of milk
are left and to remember to show up no
later than 7 o'clock this kind of
bossiness sounds as if there's no love
left but the desire to control
procedurally is often a symptom of a
fear of losing one's partner emotionally
one has to feel quite out of control to
become controlling the sternness is
really a misguided plea for closeness
the real message has nothing to do with
the table what it means in truth is that
one senses the partners lack of trust
and devotion and is resorting to
exercising practical control over their
life in order to achieve some kind of
control over what one really wants to
get a handle on their emotions one would
stop if one felt more reassured of their
love controlling behavior is a bid for
affection delivered as a barking order
most of the time what people really mean
in love is kinda more tender and more
poignant than what they manage to say
but there are also times when the
surface is sweet and the reality firedog
as Marcel Proust knew in love it is
often the one who loves less who makes
the tender speeches the partner may be
fooling us and themselves in a
sentimental direction exaggerating all
its pure good and simple when we
translate their words we should get
fruitfully suspicious perhaps we've set
the bar of being honest too high
we've created a situation where we are
refusing to accept difficult news and
they're ambivalent complex emotions
quite possibly with a little more
open-mindedness in softwa we could come
to deal well enough with the darker
parts of our partners but for now we're
engaged in a dangerous collusion to keep
our fears at bay thereby allowing them a
higher chance of becoming realities in
the ideal future we will have in our
ears little devices that will translate
our lover's words into what they mean we
will hear via our discreet brushed steel
appliances nor what they overtly say but
what they are attempting to communicate
and ideally they'd be wearing one too
for the challenge of translation is of
course always a mutual one until that
time though we should always make the
effort to decode the messages that we
receive accepting that it's a legitimate
part of the effort of love to interpret
rather than just to listen to another
person's words
you
you